new york wird ihnen präsentiert von der
airline wo im deckel riol ii welt bringt
new york stolz schön faszinierend die
vielleicht legendärste stadt der welt
aber auch hektisch und chaotisch wir
begleiten fünf schweizer und
schweizerinnen die den sprung über den
großen teich gewagt haben um sich dort
ein neues leben aufzubauen eine
herausforderung nicht umsonst heißt es
wer es in new york schafft schafft es um
wahl auf der anderen seite bietet die
stadt demjenigen der es wirklich will
nach wie vor unbegrenzte möglichkeiten
[Musik]
fünf uhr morgens in queens daniela
fischer superman fährt mit frank neusel
nach pennsylvania frank ist metzger und
hat bisher danielas bratwurst
hergestellt aber er hört auf nun suchen
sie einen neuen metzger
[Musik]
und mache die braut ist mit ihm zusammen
die rezeptur hast du mit
nach eineinhalb stunden kommen sie in
pennsylvania an
wenn maja gehört diese wusste er ist
deutscher und könnte die würste
reproduzieren
in den usa gibt es keine klassische
berufslehre daniela arbeitet daher am
liebsten mit europäischen metzger denn
die haben die handwerk richtig gelernt
[Musik]
am ufer des hudson river an der upper
west side hat sich fashion stylistin
anna zu verbringen
[Musik]
die 34 jährige hat vor kurzem ihren
festen job gekündigt und sich
selbstständig gemacht
kraft für den neuanfang holt sie sich
beim boxen
[Musik]
und ich war schon uhr ist überhaupt
damit allein kann ich schon wieder
energie nach dann dass ich besser in
einem tag machen sich überzeugt mit
macht die reverse bei dem dax-konzern
trainer 150 dollar die stunde
workout mit anna ein freundschaftsdienst
unter sportverrückten
wenn man damit angefangen hat wird man
süchtig und man kriegt nicht genug dafür
genau wie anna sagt der sport macht mich
klar wenn ich keinen sport mache werde
ich wahnsinnig
an a bezeichnet sich selbst als sport
süchtig
je ausgepowerte der körper desto klarer
die sinne
es ist noch nicht fit mach mich mega
ausgleich und markus ruf job aufzugeben
auflage stilo philosophieren
schlecht
[Musik]
ein industriegebiet im norden problems
[Applaus]
er hat mir über designer patrick vor
einem jahr seine werkstatt bezogen für
ihn ein heiliger ort sagt der 42 jährige
hier entstehen seine kreativen möbel
das erste geschäft hat patrick für heute
bereits gemacht messe möbel für einen
kunden gehen gerade raus
emotioneller natürlich sagte stolz
natürlich dass man wieder 'ran
befriedigte und h&m
möglich um zunächst rund und das ist das
ist schlussendlich leute mal auch nicht
die beste
[Musik]
vor 20 jahren erhielt patrick ein
stipendium an einer new yorker
kunsthochschule als zeichner
möbel designte er damals aus geldnot nur
für den hausgebrauch
doch freunde waren von patrick stil so
begeistert dass er umsattelte
nach und nach verfeinerte er seine
technik edle naturell zu bearbeiten
der beginn einer großen leidenschaft
so gewaltig wie jetzt mit fez
wunderschön dass quoten reden wir jedes
mal mit den sounds wirklich spiel
kreiert das ist schon schön
dass jetzt eine ganz fertig ist so die
drei möglich sind
so hussy firma hat mich aufstellt deine
songs verkaufen hans möbliert und
michalski angestellt zum die möbel quasi
als leihgabe und sarah jessica parkers
sie so und das hat sie jetzt verkauft ja
da sind jetzt zwei würde auch sie sind
und mir gesagt aus über 220 millionen
ernst das haus verkauft
an der upper east side strahlt heute
nicht nur die sonne vor christina und
greg liegt ein besonderer tag
ihre einjährige tochter lena wird
getauft
in der lena getauft wird ist eine
protestantische kirche nicht nur der
glaube sondern vor allem die
gemeinschaft war den eltern wichtig
wir leben in einer schwierigen start der
schwierigen welt und das ist wichtig
eine basis zu haben und gemeinsame werte
die man teilt und das wollen wir unsere
tochter weitergeben
besonderes highlight gregs vater tom
selbstfahrer ist extra angereist um
seine enkelin zu kaufen
er ist extra aus knoxville tennessee
gekommen und freut sich ungemein
daniela versuchte er weil das rezept für
ihre star wurst zu perfektionieren für
sie ist klar dass nur bio fleisch
verwendet wird
mittlerweile ist auch danielas
geschäftspartnerin john russell
eingetroffen mit ihrer firma star wurst
wollen die beiden die schweizer
bratwurst auf dem amerikanischen markt
lancieren
das erfolgsrezept für die echte wurst
lernt kennen heute aus erster hand
ich bin extrem happy will ich wirklich
ticken einfach marktführern super seiner
arbeit möglich ich hatte keine klischees
zum probieren will glaubt der fraktion
sieht alles so schnell gegangen maschine
ist so groß wie muss noch schliefen zum
sie perfektionieren
300 würste wollen frank und kennen heute
probeweise herstellen an der mischung
wird gefallen
bei der größe ist angela noch ein
bisschen skeptisch
nach 45 minuten sind die würste fertig
daniela will sie am wochenende bereits
verkaufen vorausgesetzt sie schmecken
habil
macht der fed die auch sofort so
ist es nur das gleich mal die hitze
gekommen hat keine kühlung möglich und
dann dann wird die dunkle locken sie
hatten sonnenbrand jetzt
700 wurster will daniela jeden monat bei
kein bestellen kostenpunkt 800 dollar
die berühmte fifth avenue hier hat
uhrmacher harry beutler seiner werkstatt
um die mittagszeit herrscht hochbetrieb
der 55-jährige kam schon vor 30 jahren
nach new york als er die chance bekam
ein eigenes geschäft zu eröffnen hat er
sie gepackt
eine von den bürgern warum dass sie die
hardware des ccee dass logan denn zum
motto der schule ist sie dem schweizer
uhrmacher steht die welt offen und
übrige vermögen umkreist als junge burg
mit der weltesche noch mit der defterli
noch mit der interrail und wohnen woche
geleert haben vorrang hat gewusst dass
sich russland wort und ja noch zwei
jahren musste und habe ich die
möglichkeit auf südafrika auf new york
und ja das ist wirklich passiert
[Musik]
harry ist dienstleister auf reparaturen
gibt er ein jahr garantie wenn doch
reklamationen kommen heißt es freundlich
bleiben und den fehler finden im falle
dieses jungen mannes ist das schnell
passiert wo ich das
recht vor der bar woche gemacht hat und
das eigentlich für einen studienabbruch
nicht wenn man die schulen ersetzen und
den seit juni laufen
gelöst zeit fürs mittagessen
die zeit
dann hast du in
kliniken wollen und dass wir schauen
kann nicht aber der gehört nicht
wirklich sagen wie viel gebracht weil
das meine partei und mittagspause
dass ich eine zeit wo die ufer oben
verbessern und wagengruppen kraft unsere
orte blieben ich glaube ich haben wir 20
jahren bin ich dreimal zweimal
ökologische
gewissen zustand bin einfach so
in der pressetermin church an der
madison avenue erhält die kleine lena
band aufsägen
dass sie ihn von ihrem opa tom erhält
der selbstfahrer bau ist eine ausnahme
und macht die taufe für die eltern noch
wertvoller
[Musik]
mit
sehr emotional gesehen hatte auch
gezeichnet war das so emotional würde
ich die hausmeister sind grosse moment
ist aber
wichtige büros
passiert das ist schön sie sich vor ich
unruhig sie und auch darauf nicht so
ganz wohl
[Musik]
nach der messe wird gefeiert
standesgemäß in christinas und greggs
penthouse an der organist sollte
patentante nanny gregs familie fast alle
sind gekommen
christinas eltern haben es nicht
geschafft der hohe preis den man zahlt
wenn man fern von zu hause lebt
ja natürlich
sehr schön
und
amerika
kulturell
und nicht sein dass eine besser gehalten
als in der kulturelle unterschied was
geht zurück in dunklen patrick und
assistent alex beginnen heute mit einem
neuen auftrag ein kinderzimmer für
45.000 dollar holz ist en vogue doch das
material erfordert äußerste sorgfalt
[Musik]
sind dann darum benehmen haben sich
weniger schnell und
das muss natürlich alles stimmen oder
vor allem in den preis groß sein
assistent alex hat sich vor zwei jahren
für ein praktikum beworben inzwischen
arbeitet der vollzeit in der werkstatt
für 16 dollar die stunde
obendrein erhält er eine ausbildung die
er sonst in amerika nie bekommen würde
er ist ein ziemlich entspannter typ
vielleicht ist das etwas amerikanisches
er ist auch sehr genau aber gleichzeitig
verständnisvollen dadurch lerne ich sehr
viel
ich kann also auch mal helfen oder sogar
einen fehler machen weil er nicht
nachtragend ist
trotzdem motiviert er mich ständig dinge
besser zu machen
er hat jetzt quasi alles beim ihr
handwerkliches
in amerika hatten wir nicht machen wir
karriere wie jetzt in die schweiz wo man
im kurs lernen oder das lernt man
einfach machen oder in zwei shows finde
ich es schon wichtig dass man die
nächste generation den gelingt einfach
bringt und dass
das dach seiner werkstatt land pause
macht er wie alle anderen zwischendurch
patrick hat seinen erfolg nicht geplant
und zweifel daran von seinem talent
leben zu können plagen ihn bis heute
und das hat sich ja schon klar dass man
das jetzt
schon da einfach aber ich mit ihren
studien ist gelernte auf
alltag auch in queens ihr wollt daniela
mit ihrer familie vor ein paar jahren
hatten sie glück und konnten ein kleines
reihenhaus kaufen das dorf in der stadt
der supermarkt liegt gleich um die ecke
die qualität der lebensmittel sei viel
besser geworden in den letzten zehn
jahren findet daniela
als bratwurst expertin welt ihr
kritischer blick natürlich auf die
einheimische konkurrenz
amerikaner gelten als oberflächlich aber
daniela gefällt der freundliche umgang
hier viel besser als in europa
daniela fühlt sich erst seit drei jahren
so richtig zu hause hier als sie vor 15
jahren nach new york zog war für sie
klar dass sie nach zürich zurückkehren
würde
[Musik]
ich werde auch noch
mit dem gedanken
bevor ihr sohn in die schule kam zog
familie schon mal nach zürich für
ehemann neal war es aber schwierig als
musiker zu arbeiten und seine musik
label von der schweiz aus zu leiten und
so mussten sie nach einem jahr zürich
nach new york zurückkehren
[Musik]
broadway ecke fausten street am rande
des hippen new yorker stadtteils so ist
falschen stylistin anna auf dem weg zu
einem termin
als freelance er ihn muss sich ständig
kontakte knüpfen zudem will sie mit
ihrer tunika linie die modewelt erobern
heute besucht sie den designer sieg der
deutsche ist mit seiner eigenen
kollektion bereits erfolgreich in new
york
seine designer klamotten gibt es nur in
kleiner stückzahl entsprechend hoch ist
der preis
die kostet ungefähr 1500 sie hat keine
mode schule besucht er ist einfach
entdeckt worden auch das ist new york
ich bin zufällig in die mode reingeholt
right time
space habe ich den leuten die mich
prüfend war mein style gut und es ging
dann gesagt so was will gott nicht so in
deutschland oder schweiz passieren weil
da muss man mal was neues studieren und
es ist einfach als wissen so recht
glauben ich habe hier ist es so richtig
wo ein wille ist wo du dein traum ist es
zu merken in dem sinne anna hofft dass
auch ihr american dream war wird sie
nutzt die chance und zeigt sie bilder
von ihrem eigenen projekt den tunikas
spezielle gewänder für frauen vielleicht
hilft
ich suche mir sein ratschlag und
kompletten business levels und ich wenn
ich das in deutschland so richtig einig
und darum ist auch schön wenn man einmal
selbständige schon alles es geht auch um
die eigene person das muss aber für
visionen gesehen weil das vorteile mit
es mit musik
[Gelächter]
auf zum nächsten termin den künstler
sebastian jung kennt anna noch aus der
zeit ihrer festanstellung der franzose
hat sich auf installationen
spezialisiert auch dieser kontakt könnte
irgendwann einmal etwas nützen als
stylistin sucht anständig gute locations
und immer trifft man auf eidgenossen
auch wenn es nicht so aussieht momentan
bedeutet jedes treffen arbeit networking
bieten doch termine wie mit sebastian
gehören zu der netteren sorte
grundsätzlich extrem interessierten
glied und
irgendwo chance
das projekt
sogar verdient oder nicht wo also nicht
authentisch und nun wieder portfolio
bilden tragen woher affäre der sprung in
die selbstständigkeit war für anna eine
rettung jetzt können sie wieder selbst
über ihre termine bestimmen davor
arbeitete sie lange in einer
werbeagentur und war dort irgendwann
ausgebaut
vor einem tag auf den anderen gespürt
ich muss aber ich sag das dann so
einfach wie verstößt also ich
wahrscheinlich eine schlaue möchte kann
immer nur vor dem computer und auf
brandes im terminplan so zu schaffen und
das ist für mich jetzt hat es die matif
freiheit wird etwas extrem anstrengend
ist
und 7 hat eine schwester saarland wo
jeder monate nach und ich glaube es ist
fast rastloses leben was mir hat
persönlichem entspricht was aber für
viele sagen dass ich wie das was sie so
stresst im frühjahr im moment sehr genau
die bereiche energie aber ja ich bin oft
an der fifth avenue läuft das geschäft
harry beutler krank für die uhrenfirma
radu nach amerika und eröffnete bald
sein eigenes geschäft da über ein
drittel der new yorker ausländische
wurzeln hat kommt es immer wieder zu
überraschenden begegnungen
deutsch
manchmal gibt es ganz spezielle bender
wie zum beispiel so was dagegen nur das
band von jubel und pasdaran service ist
kann es dabei dass schon nichts was uns
angst übertragen ja wo sind sie
meldungen stock ich bin auf 13 12 und
sie und da sind sie schon lange her im
gebäude
ich bin deshalb dann letztes jahr eine
andere aliasnamen gesehen
okay wenn man deutscher ist der schweiz
gewohnt hat sich in den 60er jahren
sechs jahre nutzern
dann der geht man schon auf die
schweizer nationalflagge ich meine dass
es für uns ein qualitätsmaßstab der war
existiert ich bin auch ein fan von roger
federer muss ich auch sagen
schweizer qualität und die gute lage
zwei garanten für harrys beruflichen
erfolg
wir sind jetzt mit zehn mann hätten wir
so viel besser als sie das lokal ist mit
über 200 euro im monat
harry mag seinen job und er verdient
damit genug geld um sich einen haufen
hobbys zu leisten die sind ihm ebenso
wichtig
segelfliegen und auch motorradfahren ein
hobby das er mit ihr geteilt harry hat
sein glück gemacht aber dafür auch
einiges getan
dass die wirklichkeit
aber ich glaube alles glück die
persönlichkeit
ich glaube die ganze kombination
zusammen ich glaube dass ich es viel
weniger wirtschaft also die
oldtimer-messe ka finanz corporation ein
highlight für autofans aus ganz kanada
harry ist stammgast
und schweizer understatement für einmal
weniger angesagt im gegenteil mit seinem
treffer kann sich harry sehen lassen
bis zum zeigen was du hast eine replika
von bmw
19 40 50 jahren zu
russland in russland geboren aber als
wie ein antiker wohl reichen foto
stephan lohse jetzt ist mehrere traktor
aber macht spaß endlich samstag für die
beiden vollzeit juristen christina und
greg heißt dass familientag mit tochter
lena und zeit mal wieder den big apple
zu entdecken
[Musik]
zwei familien samstag gehört auch der
besuch einer deutschsprachigen
kindergruppe
leiterin barbara ist schweizerin
was sie macht
das ist für mich
hin und wieder bar und
[Musik]
schmierereien mit lerneffekt für die
eltern auch eine investition in die
zukunft ihrer kinder
meine eltern haben nicht auch gefördert
französisch zu lernen und deutsch zu
lernen so glaube ich dass es wichtig ist
mehrere sprachen sprechen und jetzt ist
die richtige zeit die sie so klein ist
und es ist auch zum beispiel so dass das
klingt jetzt alles sehr berechnet aber
wenn unsere kinder fließend deutsch
sprechen bei karlstadt actions wenn sie
das ausweisen können dass sie deutsch
sprechen und sie hat praktisch ein
studiengang wählen wo irgendwie deutsch
literatur dritten sind großen vorteil
das schulsystem ist das große thema in
new york und die optimale förderung der
kinder ebenfalls christina und greg
lassen es mal auf sich zukommen es muss
keine eliteschule sein
so dass man sich relativ frühe muss auch
vorne verlegt was man mit dem rauchen in
öffentlichen schulen schicken eine
privatschule aber sein dass für schüler
sehen und so und da muss man sich schon
gedanken kann man auch etwas mehr bio
ist nicht
einfach
es muss keine privatschule sein es gibt
gute öffentliche schulen in new york es
gibt sogar ein paar richtig fantastische
und es gibt welche die schwierigkeiten
haben
das ist ein problem mit dem sich eltern
in new york auseinandersetzen müssen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nur ein paar blocks weiter liefert
patrick ein weiteres möbelstück aus mit
dabei der deutsche architekt alexander
wehr scheint er hat die kunden wohnung
saniert und patrick mit der fertigung
der möbel beauftragt
die geschäftssprache der
deutsch-schweizerischen kooperation ist
englisch
englisch natürlich gäbe wäre zwar
spartanischer der bayern mit dem
alexandra deutschen ist für mich die
erste fremdsprache mich in englisch
tanken und dann vom englischen schweizer
das problem aber dann ist vom englischen
schweizerdeutsch hochdeutsch und dann
langsam kompliziert
12.000 dollar hat sich der kunde ein
banker das sideboard kosten lassen ein
lukrativer markt denn hier leben viele
leute mit viel geld
salzburg machte der stube tisch und dann
aber im badezimmer und ich es gemacht
und dann ist schon interessant jetzt
nach so vielen jahren in new york war
nicht im laufe der szene ist ganze adobe
idee muss auch nicht das und das und er
hat das stück
stück von mir überall in der stadt oder
und das ist schön natürlich
seit 20 jahren lebt patrick in
williamsburg es hat lange gedauert bis
er von seinem kunst leben konnte nun ist
das auftragsbuch voll zeit für hobbys
bleibt da kaum die einzige ausnahme der
tennis termin mit freunden doch vorher
muss er den müll rausbringen
[Musik]
architektur soll ich eigentlich schon
nach der studie blick hinterlegt das
ganze anderen
tennis kumpel miles ist heute der
chauffeur auf der fahrt gibt es eine
dieser typischen spontanen begegnungen
wie sie eben oft vorkommen in new york
einzigartig für die offenheit wo der
amerikaner generell natürliche new york
sowieso wo million handzahme winter
action
offen und aktiv aber wenn es um trends
wie fitness geht übertreibt man sie ja
auch gerne mal
extrem
patrick hat die herausforderung new york
angenommen und dabei immer an sich
geglaubt
viele seiner kollegen daheim er nicht
wie hannah lee nicht so jamann grund
stand wurden
dann ja auch passiert einmal new york
hat das von new york und dann ist
jährigen mann vielleicht noch nicht so
56 ist der wendepunkt plötzlich allem
ochs hat aber ein grablicht hauptstand
ich war und dann hat es quasi
akzeptieren
[Musik]
auf der automesse in conneticut bringen
wie coverstücke harrys augen zum
leuchten
der uhrmacher besitzt bereits vier tipps
einer davon gehört ehefrau heidi aber
ein solcher oldtimer fehlt noch in der
sammlung
olina wäre
die haut zeigt alleine da
und haiti haben sich vor 30 jahren im
schweizer ski club kennengelernt auch
heute sind freunde aus dem klub ihr eine
eingeschworene gemeinschaft
ursprünglich waren es nur schweizer
konzert
sklerose gruppe von schweizer wo
zahllose irgendwo haben weil er für
skifahrer und
der hand seit einem hausbau und
informant habe und er würde hätte der
klub wird langsam größer und größer
wurde mit mit mehl liegt
der nationale stück wurde skiclub kumpel
roland kommt noch nicht nach hause
ein kleiner freundschaftsdienst ist
gefragt
ehefrau heidi ist gebürtige amerikanerin
ihren schwarzer vornamen hat sie weil
heidi die lieblingsgeschichte ihrer
mutter war
ich spreche nicht fliessend
schweizerdeutsch
früher habe ich mal deutschstunden
genommen damit ich etwas verstehe er
kommt also nicht mit allen davon früher
war es eine geheimsprache er konnte
etwas sagen ohne dass ich es verstand
aber jetzt verstehe ich doch das meiste
kaffeehändler roland besucht seine alte
heimat sechs mal im jahr dass er weder
hier noch da zu hause ist stört ihn
nicht
schwitzig für mich ist schweiz still
standen in c 47 weg bin
aber ich genieße das ich finde das kein
nachteil in kapital ich find das
eigentlich sehr abenteuerlich als sich
asexuell
darunter die schweiz
jetzt ganz stolz schafft jetzt günstig
sie
new york bietet für jeden was und ist
auch viel sicherer geworden nach den
terroranschlägen von 2001 hatte der
damalige bürgermeister giuliani dieses
anliegen zur chefsache gemacht
heute lieben es christina und greg in
ihrer freizeit in der stadt herum zu
bummeln was ich ganz anders wo man gerne
wohnen was man sich ob mich irgendwann
so viel geld haben um sich im internet
oder weniger das gibt es oft auch wo man
sich dann überlegt wo man welche wohnen
hier geht's wahrscheinlicher fusion aber
gefährlich im sinn gab es wirklich
der center parcs dreieinhalb
quadratkilometer natur für acht
millionen menschen da kann es
anscheinend haben schon mal eng werden
[Musik]
natürlich überhaupt jedem park ist das
immer so das sieht man aber mit syrien
sega zum beispiel ist empfehle ich will
natürlich müsse aber die jetzigen
italienischen das extrem lustig wenn
verschiedene lüge und höhenunterschiede
nicht was ich sehe und nach vorne steht
[Gelächter]
christina ist in der umgebung von zürich
groß geworden umgeben von vielen natur
die muss sie sich hier ein bisschen
zusammensuchen
[Musik]
ich muss ehrlich sagen wenn ich jetzt
führe zum beispiel schlug dann kann das
ist natürlich schon irrsinnige
lebensqualität in der schweiz wo man da
aber wohl schwierigere ist um die
qualität
hat die sachen abwägen und fähigkeiten
wieder mal zurück nicht ewig immer da
wahrscheinlich aber im moment ist es
wichtig für mich
ich könnte mir schon vorstellen in der
schweiz zu leben ich liebe es in der
schweiz zu sein aber es ist
unrealistisch dass sich dort ohne
deutschkenntnisse mein beruf ausüben
kann
ich bin ein new yorker anwalt und
prozess ihre vor amerikanischen
gerichten
[Musik]
nachmittag bei der familie showman leon
und lehne dürfen ein wenig fernsehen
daniela geht heute abend aus niehl und
seine band geben ein konzert
die babysitterin ist schon da
babysitterin gabriel war bringt leon und
lilly später ins bett
ausgang ab und zu tut gut als die kinder
noch kleiner waren war der alltag in new
york für daniela nicht immer einfach
[Musik]
ist das besser
in einer alten fabrikhalle gibt einen
nachtflohmarkt lille spielt später noch
mit seiner band
das lässt sich daniela nicht entgehen
auch wenn die wilden jahre längst vorbei
sind
konzert und donte und trinken zwei drei
monaten wenn er spielt dann rot was mich
interessiert den kaum hier vertreten er
klebe daheim
seit 14 jahren sind nil und daniela
mittlerweile verheiratet ob alle die ihr
mit einem schwarzer mann anders wäre
kann sie nicht beurteilen aber
die fans akzeptiert wehrmacht kompromiss
kompromiss machen dass ich blind
kompromiss
[Musik]
nils band die dave king scott schon
erfolgreich mit stars wie amy winehouse
und bruno mars zusammengearbeitet
sogar einen grammy hatte saxophonist und
prozent gewonnen
[Musik]
doch während des ersten songs muss
daniela bereits nach hause die
babysitterin wartet auf die ablösung
[Musik]
ausgeh abend auch für anna freundin
bettina ist da ebenfalls schweizerin
klar dass anna ihr erstmal die tunikas
zeigen will doch lange über mode
geplaudert wird nicht die beiden wollen
noch freunde treffen ganz spontan wie
fast immer in new york
[Musik]
ich würde mich
fertigmachen zur abfahrt
heute geht es stilecht im yellow cab zum
club
das ist aber nicht immer so
es war rechnet man mit dem velo aber
in den oscar
anna hat in den letzten jahren viele
kontakte geknüpft aus einigen wurden
sogar echte freundschaften
einen festen freund hat sie momentan
nicht sie sucht aber auch nicht gezielt
denn was das angeht zeigt sich dass
hippe new york immer noch erstaunlich
altmodisch
[Musik]
sowieso sind sie
standard mir ist alles viel schneller
kategorisiert
geschrieben ich bin die besonders die
viertplatzierte freundschaftsspiel
also sie stärkten füßen hirsch lama
sowie dating
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge harry auf hoher
see mit an bord ehefrau heidi und die
beiden söhne
[Musik]
fashion expertin anna in action
fotoshooting über den dächern von
brooklyn
außerdem auf dem fußballplatz gibt leon
sein bestes
[Musik]
und daniela testet ihre neuen würste am
publikum aus
[Musik]
order new york schiene for smes
präsentiert wurde der airline wo in die
welt bringt